jung-hoon depart all I need for you is
to bring your current CV ring okay
contacts are his stock and trade his
network has been growing steadily for 25
years on all foolish uber Jesus event
project fewer does VZ Ferguson Harmon
Michel tippmann earns his money by
placing executives in new positions
mid-sized companies are his hunting
grounds as a personal consultant
companies commissioned him to find
capable candidates for their top
managerial positions he and his partner
have just moved into a new office in a
top central Berlin location as a vent
when someone visits us and is fairly
well known and people see he's going to
a headhunter they'll wonder if he's
looking for a job
so the more discreetly things go though
and how have you solved the problem
Yahya modest had sawdust he months when
going into the building downstairs has
picked up and taken in the elevator
right up to the office level there's no
hallway
they're brought directly to a consultant
without running across anyone else
careers are made in this simply
furnished office his greatest challenge
is finding women for executive positions
there are scarcely any applicants
but in tapas it's shown is this one that
seen only 10% of top positions are
filled by women it's slightly better in
middle management and it's very
different from branch to branch if I'm
looking for executive personnel for
energy companies whether I talk to
people directly or take out an ad I
can't find any women in the building
trade virtually no women with
architecture firms on the other hand
there are lots of women beautiful for
this client tippmann already has a
definite project in the arts sector the
client has come here specially from
Hamburg he's a marketing specialist with
experience as a managing director on
international projects now he's looking
for a new assignment and hoping for good
advice he'd be willing to relocate to
Paris
this film is titled meme okay
that's why there's a multinational
aspect here dealing with other cultures
if I remember rightly you were in Qatar
for quite a while just how long were you
there
B'Elanna fancied up for odd the jobs
tippmann deals with pay up to several
hundred thousand euros annually on top
of that he takes a percentage of the
first year's salary
the companies pay his fee just how much
that is he doesn't say
this company has used him as a
headhunter for nearly ten years six
months ago he found them a new technical
system supervisor now he wants to know
how it's all worked out the new
supervisor used to work in the solar
industry now he's in charge of more than
a hundred employees divided into two
locations in addition to technical
expertise the Executive Board also
wanted someone they could get along with
a case for tippmann default head is it's
Dutchman now the advantages that we meet
people we don't see when we just place
an ad so we're speaking to people who
want to change jobs and if a personnel
consultant discreetly makes contact the
person we speak to would have thought in
advance about whether to take this job
rather than another placement and I'm
not off of our names or that Michele
tippmann is about to talk to businesses
and personnel managers passing on some
of his negotiating tricks and advice
because in Germany executive positions
are being filled more and more quickly
and it's a lucrative business for
headhunters